in gaza residents celebrate the
ceasefire between their hamas rulers in
israel
[Music]
they see it as a win despite more than
230 deaths
including children 12 died on the
israeli side
but this is a fragile calm
i say that today this battle stops but
netanyahu in the whole world should know
that our hands are on the trigger
and that we will continue to ramp up the
capabilities of this resistance
and we will tell netanyahu and his army
if you come back
we will come back
in israel there's relief prime minister
benjamin netanyahu agreed to a ceasefire
but also worry i think it's good the
ceasefire is good for
humanitarian reasons to let civilians
relax a little bit on both sides i'm
skeptical though that it will really be
kept for a while
the government here too claiming success
from 11 days of airstrikes
we had some very clear aims for a
military aims that we wanted to achieve
and we believe we've achieved those aims
and therefore we've gone into
effect with the ceasefire brokered by
egypt but this is unconditional but at
the same time if hamas fire on us again
it should be very very clear that we
will react that we will not allow
any rocket fire whatsoever into israel
the u.s welcomed the breakthrough but
wants to see
a more lasting peace i believe the
palestinians and israelis
equally deserve to live safely and
securely and to enjoy equal measures of
freedom
prosperity and democracy my
administration
will continue our quiet relentless
diplomacy toward that end
for the nasa family the chance of calm
couldn't come soon enough
she and her family eat a simple meal
gifted by their neighbours
like so many in this blockaded enclave
the hostilities
have left their homes scarred food
scarce
and children scared a halt in the
fighting
could well mean more urgently needed aid
will finally be able to enter
debrahim sky news on the israel gaza
border